my father took his own life
he had terminal cancer
and he took himself off without telling
the family so as not to implicate them
and he died alone
in his car
and i felt
very angry that he had to do that
it's a controversial debate
assisted dying has divided opinion for
years
i've had patients who i thought had a
prognosis of months or even weeks
they've been alive years later
but what exactly
is it and could it really become legal
in the uk
assisted dying is the legal right for
terminally ill mentally competent people
to choose to end their lives different
countries have different rules about who
can choose to die this way well
i feel very strongly and passionately
about it right now it's illegal in the
uk
three years ago i got diagnosed with an
incurable illness a bone marrow cancer
and i thought well what do i want to do
and it was pretty clear to me that i
wanted to
take my own life at a time when i wanted
to
when pain was becoming intolerable it's
not something i want to do i'm certainly
not suicidal and i want to live for as
long as possible but i don't want to go
through the last throws and in the
indignity
of of dying
possibly with incontinence
in terrible pain racked with terrible
pain
previous proposals to change the law
have said that two doctors should assess
each request the person applying would
then be given drugs to take to help them
die when they feel ready
it's a popular idea with the public
a 2021 survey found that 73 of the
general population supported so-called
doctor-assisted suicide for terminally
ill patients 53 percent of people also
supported allowing doctors to help
people suffering from painful incurable
but not terminal illnesses to die
despite that support repeated attempts
in the courts and in parliament to
legalize it have all failed
order order
the ice to the right 118 the notes to
the left 330.
the law as it stands is antiquated
my father killed himself with carbon
monoxide poisoning and the car caught
fire the first thing i knew about it was
the police ringing up and saying we've
found your father in a burnt car i had
to go and identify his body
and that was the most horrendous
experience
i think just the anguish that he must
have gone through he was a very brave
man
but i felt so strongly that he shouldn't
have had to do that because we all
deserve
i think to have a dignified death
some campaigners are fiercely against
the idea they worry it could be open to
abuse and force people to think about
ending their lives when they may not
really want to
i think for the public my concern is
that people don't understand what they
can do already in law they can refuse
life prolonging treatment they can
refuse any treatment they must be looked
after clinicians have a duty of care to
look after them as they die of their
disease but the biggest problem is that
we know that doctors and nurses are not
good at picking up pressure on people we
know from oregon that 53 percent of
people said that fear of being a burden
or feeling that they are a burden was
one of their concerns about end of life
pain came way down the list so these are
social issues that are driving people to
feel that they need to end their lives
early
anyone in switzerland provided they
don't do it for selfish reasons and they
have the help of a doctor can legally
end their own life
other countries like spain canada and
the state of oregon in the u.s also
allow assisted dying but switzerland is
notable because it allows non-residents
to travel there to die
and people from the uk go there quite a
lot
since 1998 the swiss non-profit charity
dignitas has helped nearly 500 britons
take their own life the second highest
of any country in the world on average
20 people travel there from the uk every
year and it's legal for britons to go
but it's also very expensive even
without travel dignitas says it can cost
between six to eight thousand pounds
depending on funeral arrangements to end
your life this way so not everyone can
afford to go
assisted dying is about to be debated in
the house of lords for the first time in
six years baroness meech's plan includes
more safeguards than previous
suggestions it says that two doctors and
a judge have to sign off on anyone
wanting help to die we do have a clear
majority
in in the house of lords which you know
we just about had i think when it was
last tested six years ago but it's much
clearer today
the medical community is also changing
its stance in september 2021 the british
medical association which has
historically opposed a change to the law
adopted a neutral position that means
they won't oppose or support a change to
assisted dying law
if the bill goes through the house of
lords and campaigners think they have
enough support for that to happen then
it would be up to mps to debate and
decide and some think there's enough
support there for it to pass for the
first time ever
but while there is support across the
country some are still wary
we know that there are deficits in care
hospices are funded out of charitable
money they're not even nhs funded yet
and yet we're saying here we are we'll
have doctors supply lethal drugs to
patients against some criteria that you
can't
assess objectively and properly
scotland is already ahead of westminster
there could be a vote in the scottish
parliament on assisted dying within just
18 months and campaigners think the
plans will get the go-ahead with strict
safeguards i think palliative care as
you say has moved on hugely but if
baroness meecher's bill becomes law
there are so many safeguards in place it
would only cover people who were in this
last six months of their lives and were
suffering from a terminal illness it's
our autonomy our individual right
[Music]
you